okay the organizers um so i'm going to
talk about
deep robusta deeper rail and as you can
see i also joined nvidia so
it's techno and nvidia um
so uh um so uh we're going to talk today
about the classical
ariel model uh states uh transitions
rewarding and actions um i think
i don't need to introduce that so in the
classical approach
we know the state space so we don't have
kathy's problem we know the state space
we know the action that are available to
us
but as in most real problems we do not
know the transitions
and know the reward and in this talk
today we're only going to talk about the
classical
discounted objective everything is
simple like nothing is
uh unusual uh in terms of of the reward
function
and just you know we know that our model
is not correct we know that it's not
in rl it's never the right model but we
hope that it is
uh useful uh so today we're going to
talk about what happens when
you believe that your model is not
correct you believe it changes
uh with time and you believe that uh you
still want to do something
about solving the problem at hand
so why should you we be robust so
uh you want to be robust so here is an
example of a pinball domain so you look
at uh
you imagine that you you want to get
the blue pinball to the red target and
you have two uh uh
two possibilities you can go from the
higher uh route
and this route is going to take longer
but it's uh safer
uh because if the uh if the pin if the
pinball table
shakes you're not going to hit the wall
if you hit the wall imagine to go back
to the previous point
or you can try to go through the lower
uh
lower trajectory which is uh shorter but
riskier so how would that look look like
in terms of time
so what you see here is on the excesses
time and the yx probability and you'll
see the distribution of time it takes
you
to traverse from the origin uh to the
red point to the right target so if
you're going to choose the upper
route it's going to be safer and more
predictable
but on expectation it's going to take
longer and if you
if you're going to um if you're going to
check the lower route and
an expectation it's probably shorter but
it has a much heavier tail
uh in case you bump into one of the one
of the walls
so the question is why should you be
you'll be robust well if you want to get
to the airport remember there used to be
a time
when we used to fly uh so uh if you want
to get to the airport and your flight is
let's say here um then uh basically
you don't really care if you're going to
get uh a little bit earlier but getting
a
late uh may be a disaster uh so
but let's talk a little bit about the
meaning of robustness so we see here two
examples so on the left you see um
um the big dog and i'm sure you've seen
the movies where
somebody kicks it uh so uh this is uh
basically there's a maybe an abrupt uh
disturbance so somebody kicks uh the dog
or maybe your mole is just not exactly
what you thought it would be so here we
see two news and uh
one of them is a little bit larger than
the other so maybe you know
the dimensions is wrong maybe something
is not exactly
what you thought it would be so this is
sort of more for motivation let's uh
uh let's sort of uh identify the type of
uncertainty that we want to solve
so one type of concern is what is known
as parameter uncertainty so in parameter
uncertainty um we we don't we want to uh
find the policy that maximizes uh the
performance under the worst possible
model within a given set so i have a
there are some parameters which i'm not
exactly sure what they are and i want to
solve
i want to solve a particular uh
this max min problem and if you like you
can think about it like
as a game against nature so i choose a
policy pie
nature is going to choose the most
adversarial
parameters within a given set and this
game is going to be played for uh in
expectation and and that's going to be
my return
so that's sort of the classical robust
optimization robust control
objective which is what we're going to
talk about uh today
but before we talk about it let's uh
discuss two other types of uncertainties
the second type is what's known as risk
or
we call it sometimes the inherent
uncertainty so here over here
you have a look at cumulative reward
this is a random variable
and instead of looking at the
expectation you can look at some
risk measure for example here we have
the markovic
uh risk measure which is expectation
minus
uh a constant time the variance but you
can also look at the conditional value
at risk
or any other risk measure that you favor
for one reason uh
or the other so this is a way to sort of
explicitly
uh uh protect against the unluckiness
within a single trajectory
so everything is known here it's just
that you're not looking for the
expectation but rather for something uh
for something else
we're not going to talk about that today
and then there is a mall on character
which is perhaps the most interesting of
the
of the of the type of uncertainties
where we just don't know the models
so basically there are several possible
models that one one of them may be the
correct one and you want to find the
policy against the worst possible
model so this is not just parameters or
an unknown but the model itself
maybe even the model class is not uh is
not known
um and that's uh that's sort of the
frontier i think in terms of research
but uh
i'm we're not going to talk about it uh
today uh
as well so um so why why do we want to
care about robustness so
so we want to care about robustness when
the cost of failure is high
like in the in the application that are
mentioned here
um and i want to mention something at
the moment is never known so
um often you create them all from from a
few samples so
it's it's really there really isn't a
single model that uh
is uh is uh there there is always some
uncertainty
unless you have a gazillion uh gazillion
data points
and of course you want scalability
that's why we're going to use deep
learning we want
adaptivity that's why we'll have to
we'll want to to modify
our uncertainty set as we go along and
we want accountability i think it's
important
an interesting point here is uh that
robustness buys you accountability so
basically if you want to explain why
why you failed you can always say we
know it was out of the perimeters of the
product
i prepared to solve uh so if uh
robustness gig
buys you a an an amount of say something
like saying
this is an event that happens once once
in a hundred years
uh so uh being able to protect against
uh disturbance is something that you can
quantify
uh also by buys your explainability uh
for your performance
okay so we'll start with some old work
uh about robust mdps and explain how
they work for uh
uh for uh uh for for in deep learning
uh so i want to to make sure that the
mall is is
is clear so we have a planning problem
and there are
there's some uncertainty in the
transition then for now we know this
uncertainty so basically
in a classical mdp setting you start
from a state as zero and then you
transition
and have conditional uh transitions to
say s 1 s 2 and s 3. and uh and and we
know that uh not knowing the parameters
has potentially uh disastrous uh effect
there is phenomena called uncertainty
amplification that you basically
make a mistake initially then it it's
going to become
to have a very significant effect as
times go by
it may affect uh whatever you're going
to see in the in the distance future
especially when a discount factor is
large
i mean close to one so just to make sure
that the definitions are clear so
what is the robust mvp the same as mdp
but instead of a transition kernel
p we have a set of transition kernels
uh which we denote here by script p and
then we look at the worst case objective
so we look for the best policy under the
worst possible
model within our our set of the expected
discount of the reward
when using policy p and when uh the
adversary chooses
uh some sort of some some member of the
of the transition kernel and some of you
may say well this looks like a game well
indeed it is a game between uh
us the the maximizer and nature
or adversary who is a minimizer
okay so how do you solve such a problem
so uh
when you want you can define the robust
value function and for fixed policy
uh that would look like what's written
in the equation here so the value
function is the initial overall models
of the expectation of the discounted
return
and just to to explain the difficulty
here so so if you want to sample
uh from pi then basically you're not
sure which one transition
uh at which which is a transition you
need to simulate so suppose
i'm i'm using falsify and then uh given
the action here
this is the conditional transition so so
i'm not exactly sure
uh what should i take from this set and
there there's in this case there are
some confidence intervals
and i just don't know what exactly uh to
do or how
exactly to sample and let's suppose that
i transitioned to s3 and
now i'll be in the same problem because
i don't know exactly what is the
condition
uh probability of transitioning from sr3
to s2s4 and s5
it's within some saturn i can try to to
sample from it but i'm not exactly sure
from which uh set to sample um
so uh this is a robust uh bellman
equation it's very similar to the
standard belmont equation but here we
have
infimum over all uh all models and
and that's if you know how to solve it
and then then you can find the
the robust uh value function it's again
it's uh the same as in a classical work
it is a
a conditional it is a contraction
operator so
um it's pretty easy to solve at least
for small problems you can also
define a policy iteration here but for
large round we cannot do it
because of the usual uh uh reasons
um so let's look at a very simple
approximation a linear approximation for
now so let's suppose that
i have some feature vector phi and i'm
using a simple linear
approximation so in this case i want to
assume that
uh the value function is approximately
approximated
at the multiplication of uh of of
the features time w and i want to find w
so for start approach
basically v pi is uh
i can simply i can take rollouts
sample regress w and be done with it so
whether it's going to be efficient
or inefficient i'll use a granted
algorithm i'll use
something else that's uh less the point
the issue that i can sample
but for uh for robust problems i do not
know how to sample because i don't have
i don't know which is the worst case
model until i have chosen
uh the policy so the question is uh even
for a given policy uh how do i find the
worst case
uh uh model uh so i cannot regress
w because there is an infimum here and i
don't know how to sample
from the intimal uh the worst case model
so um so this is a bummer because we
cannot use our standard sampling
approaches but still that we can use uh
the age-old idea of of bootstrapping so
let's explain how it would look here
uh basically i'm going to uh start from
um some initial weights
and i'm going to sample uh say end
states and
and and h the k plus one iteration i'm
going to
assume that my model is perfect if my
model is perfect and
and and i already have an estimate which
is great
then um basically solving this worst
case problem is like solving a
standard standard mdp but now
the adversary is the one who's
minimizing so
finding this informal is not really
difficult it's just like solving uh
i mean assuming that i know uncertainty
that this is an easy
infimum so basically i can generate the
regression targets
solving the interval assuming that my
previous estimate was correct
so for wk class 1
just using your favorite method say
these squares
and iterate that uh forever so
basically the algorithm is really about
the sample endpoints
you modify your value function estimate
and then you sample in other endpoints
modify the valve gene estimate and so
forth
so um for at least the tabular cases it
it sort of works
we get convergence and you get error
bounds and then
what you can show you can do policy
improvement and you can derive
both a td learning type algorithm that
based are based on having a robust error
uh estimate and a deep q learning uh
algorithm that uh
is is doing the the same and all of them
are based on the same idea of
bootstrapping so
so basically assume that you're near the
solution even though you're not near the
solution
and if you do that things stand to work
out
uh you can get aero bounce when you're
close to the solution
and if you're far from the solution god
help you um
but um um basically uh things are going
to
still uh work for you so um
at this point we thought that the
problem is solved but that it turned out
that it's not quite solved so
so that two really two issues that are
uh that were
at least for me were very disturbing and
the first one is how do i build dance on
this set
so in in the discussion we have so far
it will assume that somebody gives me
the uncertainty set
and and it's not clear how how one what
i mean who would be so generous to do
that for me uh
why would i know how to build on certain
sub maybe i i got it from samples maybe
i get it from some some physical
estimate maybe i get it from somewhere
but building a sincerity set is not
something that is uh
is really easy and that's problem number
one the problem number two is that uh
um the setting that we've seen so far
was not uh
online adaptive so basically i have
monster and said beforehand
and they observe more samples i
basically don't do anything with them i
just
still solve the same problem the
question is how to adapt
uh if i have a single uh trajectory
so we'll we'll we'll briefly go through
the solutions from
for this problem we'll start for our
potential solutions
uh we'll start with uh uh the problem of
finding the uncertainty set
so we propose a very particular model
for robustness it's
it's a it's we call it the trembling
hand model so basically
uh you want to choose policy pi but
sometimes with a small probability alpha
some of the l should choose pi prime for
you and this uh somebody
is in a potentially adversarial um and
then
the idea here that uh the disturbances
of a very particular form and this form
is that somebody is going to be
the most adversarial against you but it
only has
uh this this adversary only has a power
of alpha so you cannot it cannot do
whatever it wants at any given point in
time
so this leads to the action robust uh
in this case ddpg so it's a it's an
algorithm that looks like that so you
have
uh you have an actor and a critic like
you have in
usual act actor critic algorithm and
policy granite algorithms
but you also have an adversary and the
adversary is
uh doing the the one-step greedy policy
against
uh your policy uh so uh and then
everything is trained in this loop
whether it's the same scale or not a
state stem scale or
whether it's i mean everything would
work if you uh
if you play with it enough so uh um and
and and you can think about like a nash
equilibrium so this is really what
will happen here that you're going to
get to a nash equilibrium you can prove
it at least for the teller case
um and the idea that the adversary uh is
trying to uh
essentially make life as difficult as
possible
uh for you if i can jump in just to
understand the model quickly
uh i'm guessing that for this to make
sense the
the two policies get interleaved right
so every time
your hand might tremble thank you right
so and every time step your hand sort of
may tremble uh and at least for the um
for the for the simple model that this
happened with
an id probability alpha
okay so let's see some results here uh
this is uh those are hopper and walker
uh from uh in this the well-known
uh domains and we see here the baseline
and our approach
what we see here is a noise probability
so zero means no noise this is the the
deterministic problem
and what the other axis is the relative
mass so one means
that the well this product is is
classically solved so zero one
here is a standard problem and uh and
say 0.2 and and and
0.7 mean the noise probability is 0.2
and the relative mass is 0.7 so you're
not problem solving
that you're trying to solve and we
compare
the the learned policy from the for the
baseline and and with the
uh ar ddpg and we observe the following
results
yellow is good uh red is bad and
and what we see here and that's of well
it's it's not surprising that our
algorithm works
much better when you have a noise or the
relative mass is different
but it's it may be surprising that it
works better at least
i mean when we have a relatively few
samples um even in the case where the
relative mass is one and the noise
probability is zero
and i think this is an interesting and a
result what it tells you is that
basically
robustness gives you not only transfer
transient domains
but it also gives you a modal robustness
so you're robust to the model
uncertainty not just to the parameter
incentive
and the reason for that is that i think
there is a very deep connection that is
not fully explored in
reinforcement learning between
generalization and robustness i think
there there are the two facets of the
same uh
of the same coin uh but uh at least uh
getting a precise mathematical
formulation is
has been he has avoided us at least for
uh
uh for now so uh this is i think uh an
interesting result
um and then i want to briefly talk about
uh
in the remaining time and they have
about uh how to learn that certain set
uh online
uh and i think this is uh so imagine you
have a long trajectory and you you want
to sort of
shrink the uncertainty set where uh you
start getting information and if you
don't have information because
perhaps you did not visit some states
and then you have still a large
alternative
so uh one thing you could do is you can
go beijing um
and um and basically uh uh
i'll present uh the develop development
for uh uh
for a finite state in action but uh uh
that's um
later on we'll see uh the deep
implementation so you can start with say
some digital prior and then you collect
observations
uh up to term time h and then at
time h you have an astonishing for
example you can have this one here so
basically um you look at at every state
in action and all the
all the state and action that are not
too far according to how much you
measured
uh from say some nominal transition
which is your maybe
a priori maximum likelihood uh i believe
and you can build an uncertainty set
this is good uncertainty is
a product set over state in action and
you can update it online so as you see
more and more samples you can shrink it
as as needed because you can have here a
smaller uh you have more information
so your prior uh shrinks
okay so so now you can uh uh build a
what we call a robust bellman uh
recursion uh that's a
this is a recursion in distribution so
if you accu your q
value now as a the random variable
it equals a reward runner variable plus
um
the next state q function essentially uh
for a given policy and
and and i think that's something that uh
many here
many other audiences should know but
what is what is new here is that uh
uh you can you can look at um at
the variance of of your rhino variable
and this variance of the random variable
satisfies a somewhat more convenient
uh equation so this equation now is not
an equation distribution but in an
actual equation
and let's call it w this is a violence
of
of your of of the uh of the q function
as sna it equals a constant or
something that you learned from beta and
here you have gamma squared because you
look at the second order term
and the term here the equation is very
simple to uh uh
to um uh the usual uh
robusta um bellman equation so so so now
you have once you have this equation
you can sort of figure out okay now i
have i know how to i can i can sample
i can approximate q i have a the
variance of the
of the of the uh of the random variable
which is
um the uh the cube so why why i
i why don't i approximate the normal
random variable
and that's an approximation but uh it's
it's uh
it's amenable to um uh to deep learning
in the following sense so now we can
build the network
uh the state of the usual observations
and now we have a robustular
layer that is going to give us the mean
of this random variable
and uh um a um an uncertainty robust uh
berman equation variable is going to
give us the variance
and our pro control policy is to look at
the q head to get the mean
to look at the uh urban
the uncertainty robust volume equation
had to get the variance and sample from
it so now we have uh
almost a thompson sampling like
algorithm basically
at every every step choose the action
that maximizes uh
this sampling of uh of our the random
variable representing the q
and the q uh the q value
okay so let's see what does that buys us
um so i'll i'll show you
oh uh we have about one to two minutes
before
i'm almost done um so uh um let's let's
look at uh
what we see here so this is a an
experiment where you look at uh
at uh uh at uh at cardpool um and and we
see the performance uh uh with
at the function of the poll lengths of
the average reward
uh we see that uh uh for uh the original
polling the uh
dq n is uh is pretty i mean pretty good
and then it starts deteriorating and the
pole becomes larger and larger than what
it's supposed to be
uh our approach is sort of uniformly um
not in the beginning it's is as good as
other algorithms and then it starts
deteriorating but then the problem
becomes very difficult
and uh we see that the robust dqm uh
the previous approach at least seems to
fail across the board so it's always
being overly cautious and in the
experience on the right what we see here
that uh at a time 2000 and time 3000
there are there are changes
and the robust dq any sort of performs
more or less the same
all over the place but uh the
approach which is adaptive even though
there is a change here does not care so
much about it
it's improved and then it gets to pretty
good uh performance uh throughout so
basically we had a a a an abrupt change
so imagine somebody cuts a pole
in the middle and still everything works
out
works out fine so uh to conclude uh
um i think that robustness is a really
key issue for
learning i mean we know that but that's
for from uh supervised learning and
unsupervised learning in rl we didn't
quite nail it uh
uh yet um and and just you know solve
robust mdps it's not more difficult than
solving uh
uh solving uh uh regular mdps uh it
works with deep models it's scalable
and you can even get uh theoretical
guarantees and i think that in many
applications
um especially i mean even the one that
were mentioned
in the previous talk but many others uh
this is
essential so with that i will conclude
i'll be happy to take some questions
thank you
awesome thank you shai uh yeah let's
open the floor for questions
thanks i thought that was a really
interesting talk um i had a couple
questions
one is that um it seems like some of the
ideas that you mentioned
relate to some very recent papers over
the last sort of like
four to six like four months even less
than like two to three months sort of
rediscovering the issue of pessimism as
being a benefit
which relates to the type of um
uncertainty sets that that you're
considering
do you think that um the use of
ensembles empirically often
is and maybe i'm a systematic but you
think ensembles they don't deal with
model miss specification but they may be
other ways to sort of quantify the
uncertainty sets
which is something that people using
empirically right so
so in subaru's learning we know that
that to be true so we know that say
boosting or bagging is is a um
you know quote unquote robust algorithm
there are different definitions but
let's call it robust and uh with a wink
um
um so so so yes and samples are
most likely the the easiest way to go
actually
um i mean they're they're sort of and
that they serve they buy robustness on
the cheating
because you don't have to think too much
about how to construct
and certainly set and which uncertain
state i should use and how to shrink it
and they just
buy your things for free on the other
hand they don't allow you to
think about to to know things that are
not in your data but rather a prior
knowledge
which is the biggest promise of
robustness so robustness should buy you
understanding of how the uncertainty set
look like and what you sort of don't
know
in a problem before we actually hit it
and then maybe if i could ask a quick
follow-up because i i'm also really
interested in this issue of model
misspecification
um are there any recent papers you could
from your lab that you could tell us
about that is trying to tackle this
because i think that's also one really
big limitation
um of a lot of the work i've seen
recently including our own um and not
handling that issue over the sets that
over the models we're considering
so uh i think uh this is something we'll
we'll have to talk privately but uh yeah
so uh
this is something we will actively work
on i don't know if any recent work that
is published but uh
this is uh uh so just for for everybody
on the audience uh the issue of wellness
specification is is is really central uh
because
if uh i mean specifying the model for
an rl problem is often just too
difficult or or you know
um we cannot do it or maybe it's
specified with multiple in multiple with
multiple
definitions meaning some some sometimes
with an ode
the right approach for a control problem
sometimes they actually want to go to a
state space model
um and maybe there are other multiple
agents so uh so uh
um this is central issues but you know
progress
theoretical progress at least is not is
not great i'm afraid
if i can jump in i want to ask go back
to the the first half of your talk shy
and a lot of the solution concepts
around
uh robustness are value based right
but then especially when you were
showing the the the iterative process
with value function approximation this
seems like you would accrete error
in a way that maybe isn't uh is
insufficient so i'm wondering actually
you know you talked about ddpg uh
more generally do you think that direct
policy optimization might have better
robustness
characterization and value-based methods
so the short answer is yes
i i think so i think that uh uh robust
approaches
uh that are are policy-based are are
easier to uh
to handle uh in value-based methods the
math is nicer
but then um you know as much as we like
math
it has to work eventually so because you
need to specify a lot more
about the uncertainty well for gdpg or
or in general policy-based method you
could sort of
learn the adversarial policy from uh
from data and then that makes your life
uh easier
right and you might imagine coming back
to ms point about modern miss
specification it's a little bit easier
to
to deal with that right you'll find the
best policy in the class
that's probably okay right
okay um so maybe this is uh yeah
maybe you have more questions we can
take this offline uh
um let's thanks try it again for the
wonderful talk
this concludes the last session of the
week long deep reinforcement learning
workshop
and for those who might have missed part
of the workshop all the
sections are recorded and available
online um i would like to take this
opportunity
to thank all the speakers of the
fantastic talks and
the participants for joining us uh
natalie's to say the workshop
would not have been possible without the
excellent support from the simon's
institute and the organizations of the
uh theory of our
work program i would also like to thank
the
workshop coach mark valdez for his
tremendous work and makes the
world of success i have personally
learned a lot from the workshop
and hope you find it rewarding to
generate new ideas for future research
uh mark do you have anything to share
before we
go um you've said everything so well
lihong i think i must simply
agree with you there is still a gathered
town social today
i appreciate it's friday afternoon or
friday late evening for some of our
speakers
uh but if you want to join this this is
also open thank you very much thank you
to all the speakers
for speaking this week thanks everybody
thanks thanks again everyone see you